Assalamu aalaykum. Walaykum. Asalama. My
name is Sadi. I am a student from
Kolkata, India.
My question is I invested money on a
halal company's shares 3 months earlier.
But recently I checked that the company
has become haram because interestbearing
debt to total assets has exceeded to
43.75%.
Due to which the stock has become haram
but previously the stock was halal. What
should I do? The question posed by
brother sadic that he invested halal
shares and maybe he has knowledge about
how to invest in stock which are sharia
compliant and when he invested and when
he bought these shares 3 months earlier
these shares were halal but now when he
checked up he came to know that the
interest bearing ratio or the debt ratio
has increased to more than 43.75%.
So now what should you do? First if you
have heard my answers on how do you come
to know whether the stocks you're
purchasing of a particular company Shia
compliant or not and there are five
categories. The first is that the core
activity should be halal and then you
should see to it that they're not
involved in any any interest bearing
activity as a company which is giving
loan on interest etc. Then the cash and
the debt ratio should be less and the
any haram activity should be less than
5%. These these were discussed in
detail. So the brother may have checked
and he realized after 3 months that debt
ratio has increased to more than 43% and
that makes the share. What should he do?
He should immediately sell the share.
Sell the share and invest in a halal
share. But while investing see to it
that there are two types of shar
compliant. One is that the company
itself has a Sharia board and it is
Sharia compliant by nature. By nature
means it has a board. So investing in
Sharia compliant shares which has a
Sharia board is the best. And Malaysia
where I live there are many Sharia
compliant shares and it is there in the
stock itself it mentioned Sharia
compliant halal. Okay. Not Sharia
compliant. In India there are very few
which are basically which have a Sharia
board etc. Hardly any. But even if it
doesn't have a Sharia board, it can be
Sharia compliant by nature because it
may not be a debt company. It may not be
taking loans. The the core activity may
not be haram. It may be dealing with
maybe pharmaceuticals. So by nature it
can be. So some companies by nature if
they don't have a Sharia board so it can
remain halal but some company can keep
on changing like the one you said you
invested in a company and and that
company has got involved into debt you
know. So in this you have to keep on
monitoring but the best is to invest in
shares which has invest in companies
which are the Sharia board. The second
best would be by nature it is Sharia
compliant. You know that the company
will not involve in taking loans from
the bank and by nature it is such a
company. It is a strong company. It's a
big company and it's involved in
products which are halal. And then the
third would be the company which may
keep on changing. So it is preferable to
avoid investing in companies which can
change because you have to keep on
monitoring and then if it's haram you'll
have to sell it. So why let you
investing even for a small period
whether it be a month or whether it be a
week. So best is to involve in companies
which have a Sharia board as I
mentioned. Second best is by nature if
it's Sharia compliant but now the
solution for that see to it sell it
immediately. If you want to continue
investing in Sharia compliance, see to
it that you invest in a company which
has a Sharia board or by nature it is
Sharia compliant. Hope that answers the
question.